le premier est XIV vif à ma gauche qui est
familier à la plupart d'entre vous Steve est
professeur et chercheur distingué
à l'Institut pour la
résilience stratégique et la sécurité à l'
University College de Londres et Steve
va expliquer pourquoi certains de nos
modèles économiques les plus vénérés du climat
le changement n'est pas digne de confiance et pourquoi nous
ne devrions pas compter sur eux pour prendre des décisions
sur notre avenir et ensuite il va
parler d'autres objets merci d'accord
nous savons tous que le prix nobel était
sur le point d'être décerné à nouveau l'année dernière a été
décerné à  deux personnes dont l'une était
William Nordhaus pour l'intégration du
changement climatique et l'
analyse macroéconomique à long terme et ceci est une
diapositive clé de la conférence que Nordhaus a
donnée dans le cadre de la réception du prix
Nobel, un certain nombre de trajectoires
y ont été identifiées pour la température d'ici
maintenant  et 2050 et il a décrit l'un de
ceux-ci comme optimal avec une
augmentation de quatre degrés de la température au
-dessus des niveaux préindustriels à 21h40
quatre degrés optimaux  es plus élevés que les
niveaux préindustriels maintenant, de quelle manière pourriez-vous considérer
qu'une augmentation de quatre degrés de la température par
rapport aux niveaux préindustriels est optimale,
eh bien, la logique de base était qu'elle minimisait
le coût d'un sous-sol et le coût du
changement climatique ensemble
si vous disiez que nous  nous ne savions rien du
tout, en d'autres termes, nous laissons simplement
le climat se dérouler tel qu'il est avec le
niveau de dioxyde de carbone et d'autres
polluants qui surgissent dans l'
atmosphère, puis la température supérieure
à six degrés au-dessus des
niveaux préindustriels et la valeur actuelle nette  les
dommages seraient de 23 billions légèrement
plus élevés que l'économie américaine, le coût de la
réduction est donc nul maintenant si nous optons
pour une réduction optimale qui réduirait la
température pour la minimiser à une
augmentation de quatre degrés ou jouerait environ quatre
degrés sur les dommages préindustriels
serait quinze mille milliards de moins que la
taille de l'économie américaine actuelle et le coût de la
réduction de trois
et ce sont les calculs il y a maintenant
six mois avant qu'il  a donné cette conversation à un
véritable climatologue, William Will
Stefan a décrit la probabilité d'une
augmentation de la température en degrés de
cette façon, les tropiques sont
inhabitables et la ligne de frappe
en bas là-bas la
capacité de charge maximale de la planète d'environ 1 milliard d'
humains contre sept et  un demi-milliard
maintenant maintenant comment diable pouvez-vous concilier
ces deux visions de l'avenir ce que
je pensais avant de commencer à lire ces
articles en détail était que les
économistes appliquaient un taux d'actualisation très élevé
aux mêmes estimations de dommages que j'ai trouvé
qui n'étaient pas  le cas qu'ils affectaient en
faisant leurs propres estimations en utilisant une
gamme de méthodes dont la plus
absurde est la suivante, ils utilisaient
la variation actuelle du PIB et de la température à
travers la planète et pensaient qu'ils
pourraient l'utiliser pour estimer l'impact du
changement climatique au fil du temps  c'est alors que l'
un des principaux articles regroupant leurs
soi-disant recherches empiriques a
supposé la variation observée de l'
économie  l'activité avec le climat dans l'
espace tient également les heures supplémentaires
semble très intelligente c'est incroyablement
stupide ce qu'ils ont fait, c'est qu'ils ont pris des données
sur le PIB et la température aujourd'hui à travers le
monde, principalement à travers l'Amérique et ils ont
trouvé une relation quadratique faible
entre la température et le PIB, ils ont ensuite
supposé cette même relation
s'appliquerait car nous augmentons massivement la
quantité d'énergie retenue
du Soleil en ajoutant aux gaz à effet de serre
ils l'ont appelé l'approche statistique
du nombre d'étiquettes différentes qu'ils
utilisent pour cela c'est l'un des premiers
articles à le faire pas le seul  de loin, vous avez
dit que les fonctions de réponse climatique étaient des
pays quadratiques qui sont actuellement
plus froids vont profiter aux pays qui
sont actuellement plus chauds seront nui et
la coupe transversale rassemblant toutes les
données, ils ont supposé qu'une augmentation
de la température, je pense, de trois degrés dans
ce  cas apporterait des avantages de 140
cinq milliards de dollars par an maintenant qui
est devenu un point de données que Nor  dhaus avait l'habitude
d'estimer sa fonction de dommage qui est
simplement un quadratique c'est la
différence de température par rapport au niveau
préindustriel multipliée par un coefficient
bien sûr, il devait déterminer ce que ce
coefficient utilisait tellement le symbole que
ce type de données et des données tout aussi erronées
il y a  Les données de Mendelssohn indiquent
si, avec une augmentation d'un point un pour
cent du PIB grâce à une augmentation de deux virgule
cinq degrés de la température mondiale,
ce sont d'autres qui utilisent
la même idée qui est zéro maison sa
propre contribution en quatre-vingt-quatorze en supposant
la même relation et le
coefficient a été juste  dans les articles les plus
récents, il a encore une fois réduit son
coefficient pour ce quadratique est le point
zéro zéro deux deux sept, ce qui signifie qu'une
augmentation d'un degré de la température par rapport
aux océans préindustriels entraînera
une chute de deux à sept pour cent
du PIB mondial c'est avant
en passant, ce n'est pas actualisé, c'est
simplement ce qu'ils disent, les dommages réels
seront de deux degrés  ees causera moins d'
un à un pour cent de chute quatre degrés
causeront juste une chute de trois virgule six degrés
pour cent même dix degrés réduiraient simplement le
PIB de vingt-trois pour cent par rapport à
ce qu'il aurait été en l'
absence totale de réchauffement climatique maintenant
ces conclusions  ne sont valables que si et
seulement si l'hypothèse selon laquelle la
variation que nous voyons dans l'espace aujourd'hui
sera la même au fil du temps avec l'
incroyable augmentation de la quantité d'
énergie qui serait retenue dans la
biosphère grâce aux
gaz à effet de serre supplémentaires et je me suis impliqué dans un
échange assez acrimonieux avec l'un
des économistes qui a écrit ces
GIEC reçoit des rapports depuis quelques années maintenant,
William a dit à Richard de m'excuser et
dans le cadre de cela, il a dit que c'est l'un de
ses traits dix degrés Kelvin est inférieur
à la distance de température de croissance
entre l'Alaska  et Maryland bla bla
bla le climat n'est pas un moteur principal de
revenus c'est l'une des personnes qui
rédige les rapports du GIEC maintenant un
météorologue  ist
dans sa discussion et a déclaré qu'un climat mondial de
dix degrés plus chaud qu'à l'
heure actuelle n'est-ce pas à distance la même
chose était de prendre le climat actuel et d'
ajouter simplement 10 degrés partout, la
réponse des péages à cela était de dire que ce n'est
pas le point où nous voyons les gens  prospérer dans
des climats très différents, le
déterminisme climatique n'a donc aucun
support empirique et il a finalement dit que si vous ne pouvez pas
montrer qu'il a sur l'espace, pourquoi pouvez-vous
dire qu'il tient dans le temps maintenant, ce
qu'ils ont fait, c'est qu'ils ont pris le PIB en deux
des endroits normalement en Amérique et les a
comparés alors que le niveau d'énergie dans la
biosphère reste constant vous ne regardez pas le
changement au fil du temps d'accord ce que le
réchauffement climatique fera, c'est
augmenter considérablement la quantité d'énergie dans la
biosphère perturbant complètement le
climat existant perturbant la vie humaine
ainsi qu'à la suite de cela, vous n'obtenez
aucune information sur l'impact
du réchauffement climatique en examinant les
relations entre la température locale et le PIB et je
veux  pour donner une petite
illustration simple de cela juste pour l'
exposition supposons et c'est
simplement pour l'exposition je
ne le crois pas d'
accord supposons que la température est une
somme linéaire de la température globale
causée par notre emplacement dans la Boucle d'or
zone autour de notre étoile plus
déviation locale causée par l'endroit où vous vous trouvez
à la surface de la planète et
supposons qu'il existe également une
relation linéaire entre le PIB et la
température, donc l'hypothèse qu'ils avaient était
quelque chose comme ceci Le PIB par habitant est
fonction de deux températures  la
température globale donnée par l'
emplacement de Goldilocks puis et et par
les niveaux préindustriels des gaz à effet de serre plus l'
écart local vous obtenez alpha un flammes
température globale plus alpha deux fois
la température locale et ensuite vous vous
rétablissez regardons cela pour la Floride donc l'
écart local dans  L'Amérique à sept
degrés de plus que la moyenne de l'
Amérique pour Decatur c'est dix degrés en
dessous et ensuite vous faites un calcul  en
soustrayant les deux, vous obtenez une relation
indiquant que la différence entre les deux est de
17 fois la valeur de votre coefficient
pour la variation de température locale,
vous avez annulé votre température globale,
vous pouvez alors résoudre pour alpha pour en obtenir une
estimation vous  n'avez aucune information
sur l'alpha 1, donc vous supposez que l'alpha 1
est égal à l'alpha 2 qui est outrageusement
stupide et pas seulement stupide dans un
exercice académique, cela menace
l'existence de la société humaine si
quelqu'un veut défaire le capitalisme,
ce sera l'économiste
Stu  a écrit cette recherche maintenant, c'est comme
avoir et je veux donner une illustration graphique de
ce que c'est
que d'avoir des données nord-sud sur une
montagne sans est-ouest mais
parce que c'est plat, vous dites à ces randonneurs
que marcher est-ouest est  sûr parce que le
nord-ouest est plat et que vous êtes au bord
d'El Capitan,
c'est à peu près aussi intelligent que ce que les économistes
ont fait dans ce cas et ces
données climatiques fatalement irréalistes, je suis  mettre
des virgules inversées a été calibré pour
des fonctions de dommage tout aussi irréalistes et
c'est la difficulté car nous essayons de
représenter graphiquement quelque chose que nous n'avons pas vécu,
donc je veux dire que nous pouvons réellement utiliser
leurs modèles et utiliser leurs hypothèses
qui sont des fonctions de dommage quadratiques pour
regarder  à des choses que nous avons réellement
vécues parce que nous avons connu en
tant qu'espèce des températures plus basses
qu'aujourd'hui la dernière période glaciaire lorsque vous revenez en
arrière et regardez les
enregistrements de température, vous trouvez que la dernière période glaciaire était d'
environ 4 degrés inférieure à la
moyenne de 1951 à 1980  alors à quoi ressemblait la
planète à l'époque et que
prédit la fonction de dommages aux maisons nulles serait
l'impact sur le PIB si nous étions confrontés
au refroidissement global plutôt qu'au réchauffement
climatique bien il y a 20 000 ans, il faisait 4
degrés de moins, c'est à quoi ressemblait la planète La
prédiction de Nordhaus qui le
ferait  réduire le PIB de 3,6%, il
mérite de se moquer de ne pas recevoir de
prix Nobel d'accord et pourtant c'est la
base des économistes qui disent  g nous n'avons pas besoin
de nous inquiéter à ce sujet et d'assurer aux
politiciens qu'ils n'ont pas besoin de s'inquiéter que
c'est à nouveau un pur non-sens juste pour faire
l'évident New York et B au milieu, ce
serait un kilomètre sous la glace qui
n'affectera pas le PIB de plus de  3.6
vous ne pouvez tout simplement pas extrapoler à ce
monde à partir de nos données actuelles, mais c'est
ce qu'ils font maintenant, pourquoi
ignorent-ils les points de basculement, ils en parlent
tout le temps, mais cela n'apparaît jamais dans
leur fonction, certainement pas dans les cabinets d'
avocats qu'il a réellement créés  il est moins
capable de gérer les points de basculement dans
son article le plus récent, c'est parce que vous
ne pouvez pas faire d'analyse coûts-avantages lorsque vous
avez des discontinuités, donc la réponse de
l'économiste ignorons les
points de basculement maintenant ce que dit le
climatologue et ils sont  en le
disant beaucoup plus poliment que moi, j'espère
qu'ils se joindront à moi pour être aussi
grossiers que nécessaire pour passer sur
ce front, ils disent que l'
analyse coûts-avantages a été abandonnée. Stefan a publié un article
conjoint  r avec environ 16 autres
climatologues tout récemment et ils ont
dit très modérément que la manière contemporaine de
guider le développement fondée sur les croyances
d'un changement progressif graduel ne sera
probablement pas adéquate pour faire face à cette
trajectoire, ce ne sera certainement pas le cas
parce qu'ils ne le sont pas  même en imaginant que
cette trajectoire est ce à quoi nous sommes réellement confrontés,
donc ma position après avoir lu ces données en
lisant les rapports du GIEC, nous devrions
supprimer le Kannamma gratter le GIEC
sinon celui qui devrait au moins nommer
des économistes non traditionnels qui ne feraient pas
une hypothèse aussi stupide les gens
comme moi, je peux marquer non Jared Gerard
Rosselli, il y a un certain nombre de personnes qui
font un travail peu orthodoxe sur lequel nous
n'accepterions pas cette hypothèse et demanderions
aux climatologues d'examiner ce qui se
fait maintenant, ce qui se passe parce que nous
ne le faisons pas, ce sont des listes de négationnistes du changement climatique
ou ce que je pense qu'un meilleur appel au
changement climatique banalise utilise le
GIEC pour justifier la banalisation Je n'ai pas
besoin d'introduire B  jorn Lomborg à
n'importe qui ici et écoutez quelques déclarations
de sa part.
Le lauréat du prix Nobel d'aujourd'hui vers plus de
solution climatique est l'une est une
augmentation de la température de 3,5 degrés, il cite à
nouveau l'IPC montrant que ces points de fonction de dommages de
six degrés sont susceptibles de réduire
de six à 12 pour cent des PCGR  et il
cite que le GIEC cite des économistes
pour faire ces déclarations et il
dément le fait que vous vous
impliquiez dans l'idée de
rébellion d'extinction, puis il dit que vous savez que l'
uric et le problème des impacts de l'IPC sont plus petits
que la plupart des autres moteurs,
examinons bien cela, il en fait  cite
le GIEC pour la plupart des secteurs économiques, l'
impact du changement climatique sera faible par
rapport à l'impact des autres facteurs
inclus et ils disent que l'inclusion de la
population moyenne des preuves un
accord élevé, de sorte que l'ensemble du groupe d'
économistes qui rassemblent cela
est tombé dans le même groupe  pensez à
croire que l'hypothèse ridicule que les
données sur la température dans le PIB aujourd'hui peuvent
être utilisées pour prédire t  l'impact du
changement climatique et vous ne serez pas étonné d'entendre que l'
un des auteurs est l'auteur principal de
ce document particulier, nous devrions
utiliser les données des climatologues
eux-mêmes, y compris le travail que
Stefan a fait et d'autres pour identifier
les points de basculement bien sûr  le premier de
ces points de basculement est probablement déjà
parti La banquise arctique en hiver et la
cascade qui en résultera signifiera que nous
ne pouvons tout simplement pas rester aux niveaux de
température que ces économistes
pensent être bénins, nous avons besoin de
modèles dans lesquels l'énergie  joue un
rôle fondamental maintenant aucun d'entre eux dans les
modèles néoclassiques aucun des modèles post-
keynésiens n'inclut encore correctement l'
énergie correctement Je commence à faire ce
travail avec Bruce le et Garrard et quand
nous alimentons cela et nous pouvons obtenir les deux cycliques
tous les comportements économiques suivis  par
l'effondrement économique dans cette
illustration simple particulière de manquer de
ressources mais simple et c'est stylisé
mais c'est déjà plus réaliste que
ce que Non  rdhaus a fait parce qu'il
inclut des contraintes de ressources qui sont
absentes du travail effectué par ces
soi-disant économistes du climat, donc et maintenant
vous savez que je suis un critique de l'économie traditionnelle,
ce n'est pas un secret, mais mes
critiques ici ne dépendent pas de
moi pour rejeter les choses  comme le
modèle de croissance de Ramsey et ainsi de suite, je n'ai même pas
eu le modèle de croissance de Ramsey, mais ce sont
juste les hypothèses stupides qu'ils
font, aucun économiste néoclassique qui se respecte
ne devrait tirer pour ce que ces
gens font et plusieurs
avant moi ont  sont sortis et ont dit que ce
sont ces
listes de l'année prochaine qui sont crucialement défectueuses, ils sont pires
qu'inutiles,
ils nous ont distraits de l'important
défi auquel nous sommes confrontés et il est temps que nous
les fermions,
merci
[Applaudissements]